Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Irgendwelche Neuigkeiten aus dem Facebook Land.
Wart's ab.
Herzlich willkommen bei LockBook Netzpolitik, dem Podcast, wo es immer früh am Morgen ist. Das das soll uns mal einer nachmachen.
Genau.
Ja, durch verschiedene Zeitzonen kriegen wir es ja sogar regelmäßig halbwegs hin, dass man irgendwie behaupten könnte, man wäre in der Nähe eines Morgens.
Ja, nicht nur nicht nur der Ball ist rund, auch die Erde, sie dreht sich kontinuierlich und produziert am laufenden Meter Informationen aus irgendeinem Ort, wo sowieso gerade morgens ist und äh
Wir nehmen das dann einfach zum Quelldatum auf, so. Wir verinnerlichen sozusagen diesen globalen Aspekt. So sind wir.
Ja, aber so soll.
Unix Times Tim kennt kein Morgen und.
So sieht's aus. Wobei, ich glaube, so richtig äh international ist das Programm heute äh nicht, wenn ich das so richtig sehe, bewegen wir uns heute doch weitgehend äh,
einer Zeitzone.
Da werden wir sehen.
Werden wir sehen. Auf jeden Fall fangen wir erstmal mit äh CE ST an na?
Achso, Central European Stand Up Time, ja, Entschuldigung.
Summertime.
Ja okay.
Ja, so ist das am frühen Morgen.
Tim ist albern, den bekommt diese ganze Fußballguckerei nicht.
Fängt schon an, den labert nur noch dumpf daher.
Na ja, man muss ja das äh trockene Programm auch halbwegs unterhaltsam rüberbringen. Nichtsdestotrotz äh wir blicken auf ein,
Urteil und zwar ein Urteil des Bundesgerichtshofs,
Der Bundesrepublik Deutschland und ähm ich bin mir nicht so ganz so sicher, ob ich verstanden habe, worum's da eigentlich ursprünglich ging,
Minus.
Ja, ganz einfach. Ähm ein anonymer Nutzer hatte auf der Webseite des Bewertungsportal Sanégo falsche Tatsachenbehauptungen über einen Arzt aufgestellt. Und zwar hat er gesagt, ja äh,
Da gehe ich nie wieder hin, ich habe drei Stunden im Wartezimmer äh gesessen, bin ich drangekommen und irgendwie die Akten liegen da lose in Wäschekörben rum. So,
hat es hier irgendwie hm schlecht über diesen Arzt geäußert.
Sanégo, das ist so ein Portal, was so ja, Ärzte, Krankheit, Medikamente, da wird irgendwie alles mögliche diskutiert und bewertet und verlinkt und pipapo.
Ja, kann man, also ich finde das ja übrigens äh ganz am Rande, ähm sehr gut, wenn also ich gehe ja nur zu Ärzten, die mir empfohlen wurden.
Und zwar von Menschen, die ich persönlich kenne und äh die ich dann auch zur Rechenschaft ziehen kann, wenn die Empfehlung nicht meinen Vorstellungen entsprochen hat.
Ja.
Bis jetzt habe ich da sehr gute Erfahrungen mit gemacht. Als ich das noch nicht getan habe, habe ich schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht, deswegen tue ich das jetzt. Ähm und da habe ich auch letztens noch mit äh mit äh einem Bekannten darüber gesprochen, wie so ja, kannst du auch im Internet,
Internet kannst gucken. Nee, aber finde ich nicht gut, weil ähm das, was ich als Arzt natürlich äh mir vorstellen könnte, was andere Ärzte,
tun könnten, wäre ihrer äh ihrer äh ihren Assistenten.
Dann den Auftrag geben, jeden Abend noch eine schöne Bewertung im Bewertungsportal zu schreiben. Deswegen würde ich da nicht trauen, aber ähm.
Ja kommen wir zurück zum Thema hier also jemand hatte gesagt sie bei diesem Arzt ist es nicht gut.
Und dann hat der Arzt gesagt, ja, diese äh Äußerung verletzt mein Persönlichkeitsrecht, liebes Sanego, äh gebe mir,
den Namen des Urhebers dieser Zeilen, ich will zivilrechtlich gegen diese Person vorgehen,
und dann sind die erstmal durch zwei Instanzen gegangen, wo der Arzt mit dieser Forderung Recht bekommen hat.
Und äh dass Saneko äh dieser Negoleute sind dann jeweils in die nächste Instanz gegangen und haben gesagt, nee, das kann so nicht richtig sein, dass äh Telemediengesetz
sieht eine solche Auskunft nur bei besonders schwerwiegenden,
Ausnahmen vor, ja? Grundsätzlich haben wir die Anonymität dieser Nutzer auch äh sicherzustellen.
Und ähm das kann man den Sanégo Leuten natürlich
sehr dankbar sein, dass sie das auch äh dann bis ins Ende äh gezogen haben, denn die Folge wäre natürlich katastrophal gewesen, ja, also wenn man sich überlegt,
stell dir mal vor, jeder äh anonyme Kommentare, der irgendwo ist, ne, dann hast du nicht nur diese ähm Haftungsfragen als Portalanbieter, dass dir eben bei Kenntnis.
Du in der äh dazu verpflichtet bist äh unwahre Kommentare unter Umständen zu löschen ähm,
sondern dass du dann auch noch äh denn die Leute da verpfeifen musst, ne. Das äh wäre unter Umständen eben sehr unschön geworden,
und äh so hat es auch das der BGH dann verstanden und hat gesagt, nee, die Ausnahmen des TD Mediengesetzes, wo man so eine Offenlegung machen muss, sind so eng gesteckt
dass der Auskunftsanspruch dieses Arztes für seine lächerliche Zivilklage, weil irgendjemand irgendwas über den Wäschekorb geschrieben hat, eben nichts darunter fallen.
Beziehungsweise wie ich das hier äh rauslese aus dem Artikel, äh das jetzt explizit der Schutz des Persönlichkeitsrechts da nicht drunter fällt.
Wobei ich mir auch mich auch wundere, wie der Arzt da sich auf sein Persönlichkeitsrecht äh bezieht. Es geht ja eher sehr eindeutig um kommerzielles Interesse
Aber was dieses kommerzielle Interesse angeht und überhaupt die Inhalte dieser Äußerungen angeht,
besteht natürlich der Unterlassungsanspruch gegenüber dem Portal. Und das äh äh auch der Bundesgerichtshof hat es dann eben als erwiesen angesehen, dass diese Äußerungen nicht,
den Tatsachen entsprachen. Mit anderen Worten.
Das Portal wird äh diese Äußerungen ähm,
löschen müssen, wenn es das nicht schon getan hat. Das ging jetzt aus dem Artikel nicht hervor, den ich dazu gelesen habe, weil's eben hauptsächlich darum geht, ähm.
Um diesen zivilrechtlichen Anspruch bezüglich seines verletzten Persönlichkeitsrechtes, den der Arzt da geltend machen wollte. Das hat,
jetzt auch noch eine andere Komponente, die ich da sehe und das ist ja ein Thema, was wir hier nicht so oft behandeln, was aber
offensichtlich bei Jugendlichen eine sehr große Rolle spielt. Und das ist dieses Cyber äh Mobbing oder Cyber Bully, ne.
Grad im schulischen Bereich auch schon äh häufiger. Solche ähnlichen äh Problematiken.
Ähm ich kann die, ich bin diesen, diesem Alter irgendwie inzwischen entwachsen und habe da auch keine wirklich,
belastbare Erkenntnis drüber, wie groß dieses Problem,
ist, also in in der Zahl, im Einzelfall äh nimmt das natürlich ganz äh fürchterliches Ausmaß an für einzelne Personen, die da fertig gemacht werden. Ähm ich weiß nur nicht, wie wie äh,
zahlenmäßig groß dieses Phänomen ist. Deswegen kann ich mich da nicht zu äußern.
Ja, es ist schwer zu beurteilen, zumindest mit unserer äh Datenlage, aber es ist halt dann auch im Einzelfall eben auch keine Belanglosigkeit, weil es eben dann teilweise eben einfach äh
Schüler äh tja sagen wir mal in einem schwierigen Alter in sehr unstabile, mentale Zustände bringen kann
mit allen möglichen Konsequenzen und das tja.
Da da bin ich allerdings jetzt,
Genau, da bin ich allerdings auch vorsichtig, glaube, dass das in einigen Bereichen dieses Cyber-Bulling dann da äh stattfindet, eben auch sicherlich den in dem Bereich des Strafbaren geht,
und äh das war ja hier eben nur eine Äußerung, bei der über das Persönlichkeitsrecht argumentiert wurde.
Ja genau und der BGA hat ja auch äh hier deutlich durch äh scheinen lassen, dass also hier äh sehr wohl auch äh wenn jetzt sagen wir mal,
Was strafrelevantes ist, äh sehr wohl der Diensteanbieter da ähm zur Herausgabe der Daten an die Polizeibehörden et cetera gezwungen werden kann. Das ist vollkommen klar. Nur eben jetzt nicht an den
Betroffenen, dass der dann seine eigenen Klagen an äh streben kann.
Ich denke, in in der Form erstmal äh also ein auch ein sehr wichtiges Urteil, wenn das so nicht gefällt worden wäre, hätten wir sehr
schlimme Konsequenzen gab, weil dann eben jeder sagen kann, ja hier ich will zivilrechtlich gegen jemanden vorgehen, der da irgendwo irgendwas hingeschrieben hat, sag mal, wer das ist, das äh wäre.
Es hätte sicherlich zu Problemen geführt, ja.
Auf jeden Fall. Gut. Dann blicken wir äh ein wenig nach Süden und zwar nach Österreich. In Österreich ist was passiert.
Genau, der österreichische Verfassungsgerichtshof hat äh sein Urteil zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung verkündet.
Und äh die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist in,
Österreich Geschichte und das klingt nach einem äh Urteil, das sehr ähnlich dem dem deutschen und auch dem europäischen Urteil zu dieser Angelegenheit ist. Da gibt's sicherlich im Detail äh noch Geschmacksunterschiede.
Aber äh die Hauptargumentation ist, die gesetzliche Beschränkung des Grundrechts auf Datenschutz, was jeder äh Mensch auch in Österreich hat. Ähm,
muss.
Verhältnismäßig abgewogen werden und eine allgemeine Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist äh keine äh allgemein keine zulässige Abwägung in in diesem Sinne
und äh zulässige Eingriffe in dieses datenschutzrecht müssen also konkretisiert und begrenzt werden. Ähm.
Ja so richtig über
so richtig überraschend ist es ja jetzt nicht, dass die Österreicher sich da äh so aufstellen, weil ja von Österreich und Irland aus letzten Endes ja auch die Initiative ausging, die dann letzten Endes zu der Entscheidung auf EU-Ebene geführt hat, über die wir ja schon viel gesprochen haben,
Insofern ist das ja sozusagen nur noch eine nachträgliche Klarstellung, dass man das genauso bewertet.
Genau. Ähm am Rande dieses Urteils gab's dann noch eine,
Ja, ja, da bin ich mir noch nicht ganz so sicher, wie wir die Meldung zu ähm
Behandeln ist deswegen äh wähle ich sie nur mal kurz, dass sie sich eventuell am Rande dieses Urteils noch so herausstellt, dass Tornotes dann aber in in Österreich äh,
betreiben, unter Umständen strafbar ist. Da müssen wir aber nochmal die ausführliche Urteilsbegründung und so abwarten.
Was sich daraus ergibt, aber auch hier einen herzlichen Glückwunsch an die Aktivisten in Österreich, bei denen der Thomas Lohninger selbstverständlich auch nicht gefehlt hat.
Ja, kommen wir zu unserem äh neuen Lieblings äh Thema zu äh Facebook, ja, äh wir haben bei Lokbuchtest Politik da mal eine kleine äh Studie jetzt gemacht mit unserer unserem,
aufgestellten Portal. Quatsch. Facebook hat äh geforscht und ähm war,
da ähm ganz emsig unterwegs und hat so ein Exempel statuiert an auf weiß nicht auf welcher Basis die ausgewählt wurden, aber es waren so sechshundertneunzigtausend User.
Und,
Dort wurde halt gezielt äh der Nachrichtenstrom manipuliert und dann auch ausgewertet in Hinblick auf positive oder negative,
Emotionen, wie auch immer, die gewonnen werden konnten.
Ja, also was, was Facebook gemacht hat, ist, die haben das das Team, was den den Newsfeed für Leute zusammenstellt, das stelle ich mir sowas vor wie die Twitter Timeline oder was, ne? Ähm,
die haben diesen Newsfeed manipuliert, indem sie ähm entweder negative Emotionen,
Anteil negativer Emotionen im Newsfeed gesenkt haben oder den Anteil positiver Emotion im Newsfeed gesenkt haben oder beides.
Also wahrscheinlich durch das explizite Ein- und Ausblenden von.
Genau. Da gibt's also ein Verfahren, das nennt sich äh wo du quasi feststellen kannst, ähm oder wo du grobe.
Statistischen Kennwert dafür bekommst, ob in einer Äußerung jetzt äh eine positive oder eine negative Valenz äh überwiegt.
Hm
Und entsprechend kannst du dann natürlich sagen, okay, diese, die stellen wir jetzt da oder nicht. Das haben sie einfach gemacht. Sie haben gesagt, ähm,
Sie haben künstlich eingegriffen und den Anteil positiver und negativer Emotionen in deinem Newsfeed erhöht und verringert.
Ja? Und ähm wenn sie jetzt natürlich negative ausblenden, heißt das, der Anteil positiver steigt und äh was sie jetzt interessiert hat, ist deine nächste Äußerung auf Facebook.
Ähm und wie gesagt, es gab drei Bedingungen. Einmal negative Emotionen raus, einmal positive Emotionen raus und einmal beides raus.
Und äh das Ergebnis war, wenn sie also jetzt Negative rausnehmen, das heißt, der Anteil positiver steigt, dann.
Steigt auch die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass deine nächste Äußerung bei Facebook positiv,
emotional gefärbt ist. Ähm ähnlich äh umgekehrt, wenn sie mehr negative Emotionen dir zeigen, dass dann,
Auch der Effekt steigt, dass dein die Wahrscheinlichkeit steigt, dass deine nächste Äußerung negativ emotional gefärbt ist. Und wenn man dir.
Beides äh gleichermaßen ausblendet. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit sinkt, dass die überhaupt noch etwas sagst.
Also je weniger emotional dein Facebookfeed ist, desto weniger wirst du schreiben. Je positiver, emotionaler ist, desto.
Wahrscheinlicher wirst du positiv emotional dich äußern und je negativer er ist, desto wahrscheinlicher wirst du dich negativ äußern.
So, das heißt,
Das war jetzt auch die Meldung, die äh dann, denke ich, auf der die Runde machte. Äh Facebook hat damit experimentiert, wie sie die Stimmung der Nutzer manipulieren können.
Und haben festgestellt, sie können es. Facebook hat quasi zu Forschungszwecken die Emotionen der Nutzer manipuliert. Das ist jetzt so die, die ein, ein Satzzusammenfassung.
Ja, die aber ein bisschen äh an den Zahlen vorbei äh blickt, habe ich so den Eindruck, weil die Unterschiede doch sehr gering waren.
Ja, die Unterschiede waren irgendwie im, also in der zweiten Nachkommastelle äh vom in der von Prozenten,
es ist wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr, ein sehr, sehr kleiner Effekt und es ist auch kein Wunder, dass ein solcher Effekt statistisch äh signifikant wird, wenn du eine so große Stichprobe hast, also ähm,
Wenn deine Stichprobe, je größer deine Stichprobe wird.
Umso wahrscheinlicher wird ein noch so kleiner Effekt ähm signifikant. Das liegt daran, wie du äh signifikant berechnest. Ich habe mich ja äh,
einige Zeit mit solcher Forschung auch befasst. Ähm und habe auch mal fast ein Projekt gemacht mit Facebook,
ähm bei dem es meinen Forscher gegen der also äh Forschung über Facebook äh betreiben wollte, also nicht,
anhand der Daten von Facebook, aber.
Mit Hilfe der Nutzer von Facebook und Facebook Apps, aber äh die Art Zusammenarbeit ist da nie zustande gekommen, weil ich da irgendwie keinen Bock drauf hatte. Aber äh
für soziologische Forschung und äh psychologische Forschung ist natürlich dieses Facebook ein ähm,
absoluter Traum, weil man muss sich das so vorstellen, solche Forschung findet normalerweise statt von irgendwelchen Doktoranden und äh,
die das dann von ihren studentischen Hilfskräften durchführen lassen und irgendwie einen Kinogutschein verlosen und froh sind, wenn sie irgendwie äh fünfzig bis hundert Teilnehmer haben.
Für irgendein Experiment, was sie durchführen und was Facebook da jetzt hat mit irgendwie einer Milliarde Nutzer, wo sie einfach mal spontan ähm das runter äh Schneiden auf und sich da irgendwie eine kleine Teilmenge von,
sechshundert oder dreihunderttausend Nutzern rausnehmen. Das ist natürlich der Traum eines jeden.
Forschers in diesem Bereich und Facebook forscht natürlich sowieso andauernd an diesen Daten und optimiert da dran rum, nur was sie normalerweise machen sind
quasi Experimente, das heißt, den Effekt, den sie feststellen wollen, den sehen sie einfach in der natürlichen Variation,
Ja, sie hätten also um das hier zu machen, genauso gut einfach existente Nutzerfees nehmen können
und zwei Gruppen bilden können, nämlich eine Gruppe, bei dem gerade die negativen Emotionen im Feed überwiegen
eine Gruppe, bei der die positiven Emotionen im Feed überwiegen. Das heißt, den Unterschied zwischen den beiden Testgruppen hätten sie genau so gut aus der natürlichen Variation nehmen können. Sie haben sich aber hier entschieden.
Dass da aktiv dran herum zu manipulieren und quasi statt eines quasi Experimentes ein wirkliches Experiment zu machen.
Gleichzeitig ähm.
Hätte das Ergebnis dieses Experimentes ja auch sein können, dass es keinen Einfluss hat.
Und dann hätte sich eigentlich auch keiner da drüber aufgeregt. Aber gleichzeitig ist es ja ein wissenschaftliches Experiment gewesen, in dem geprüft wurde, ob es einen Effekt hat und das Ergebnis war, ja, es hat einen,
Also es ist ein bisschen ähm schwierig da jetzt wirklich ein eine.
Ne, ich bin da selber Wissenschaftler, da jetzt eine,
Eine bösartige Manipulation zu unterstellen. Das Problem ist aber natürlich, dass diese Menschen unwissentlich Teil eines Experimentes waren,
und das ist äh nach äh allgemeiner allgemeinem Ethos nicht,
in Ordnung. Man kann äh einen Nutzer Teil eines Experimentes werden lassen, wo sie nicht wissen, worum es genau geht. Dann muss man's ihnen aber nachher erklären. Also eigentlich müssen Nutzer informiert,
zustimmen, dass sie Teil eines Experimentes sind und wenn sie im Rahmen des Experimentes über dessen Fokus getäuscht werden, zumindest im Nachhinein darüber aufgeklärt werden, beides ist nicht geschehen.
Und ähm der Sprecher von Facebook sagt, na ja, also wenn jemand Facebook beitritt, äh,
haben wir immer nach der Erlaubnis gefragt, die Informationen zu verwenden, um unsere Dienste bereitstellen und verbessern zu können. Und im Rahmen dessen äh hätte dieses Experiment stattgefunden, sagt also ein Sprecher.
Und der Forscher sagt, ja wir haben sorgfältig überlegt, was wir da machen
und wir haben ein striktes internes Aufsichtsverfahren, das eben diese diese Forschung äh genehmigt hat. Unter normalen wissenschaftlichen äh Standards hätte man jetzt eigentlich eine Ethikkommission haben müssen und äh eben die Nutzer nicht ohne ihr Wissen an solchem
an einem solchen Experiment in ein solchen in einem solchen Experiment einbeziehen dürfen.
Und interessanterweise hatte Facebook zum Zeitpunkt dieser Forschung noch nicht in seinen AGBs drin stehen,
Daten auch zur Forschung genutzt werden können. Was interessant ist, weil die AGBs von Facebook sehr, sehr lang sind und wenn man sich echt wundert, dass jetzt das ausgerechnet nicht drin stand.
Ja. Was für ein Aufschrei. Die Frage ist, was,
Was sagt uns das jetzt eigentlich? Ich meine, ich denke, dir geht's ein bisschen wie mir. Irgendwie hat man das Gefühl, man kriegt etwas gesagt, was man vorher schon irgendwie selbst,
so gefühlt hat, dass es so sei. Ähm auch wenn man vielleicht bisher noch nichts hatte, oft auf die man es so,
Wirklich äh hätte basieren lassen können. Das gibt's jetzt, ja? Und ich denke, warum sich auch so manche da so ein bisschen drüber aufgeregt haben, das hat ja dann doch ganz gut Welle gemacht. Das war zumindest ein bisschen mein Eindruck. Ähm,
Nicht nur, dass es möglich ist, sondern das eben auch Facebook tatsächlich, also dadurch, dass sie an daran forschen, zeigen sie ja im Prinzip,
Irgendwie auch zumindest theoretisch so diese Bereitschaft, so was auch zu machen. Und jetzt nennen sie es vielleicht Forschung, ja, aber es ist natürlich vollkommen klar, dass in dem Moment,
Verschwörungsthen Szenario vorstellt mit okay, alle sind auf Facebook.
Ja und jetzt haben wir so einen einen Moment in der Zeit, wo gerade dieses fühle ich mich gut oder fühle ich mich nicht gut, sehr wichtig ist,
Also so was wie Wahlen zum Beispiel. Und wenn, sagen wir mal, in den USA jetzt halt die nächsten Präsidentschaftswahlen anstünden,
Wer weiß, ob nicht auf Facebook, ja, ist jetzt sozusagen nur so eine, so eine rein hypothetische Sache, ja?
Also auch wirklich nicht, sondern es ist halt jetzt nur so eine Fragestellung, die auf einmal so im Raum steht, so dieses,
Woher wissen wir eigentlich, dass diese Ströme nicht schon in irgendeiner Form so gewichtet werden, um eine positive oder eine negative Emotion in uns irgendwie zu steigern? Das kann man natürlich sagen, also,
nur weil jetzt null Komma null drei Prozent mehr positive Emotionen in meinen Facebook-Post auftauchen ändern sich nicht gleich Wahlen, ja? Das mag sein, aber die Frage steht im Raum.
Na da würde ich aber nochmal äh das will ich nochmal ein bisschen unterscheiden. Also,
Erstens, Forschung, Facebook macht den ganzen Tag nichts anderes, als die Interaktionen, die in diesen Dingen stattfinden, in irgendeiner Form zu analysieren.
Die ganze Zeit, das heißt, das, was jetzt Menschen der Mensch auf der Straße und der Forschung versteht.
Nämlich da guckt einer rein und bildet darüber,
ja, dass da jemand Hypothesen drüber bildet und das denken die meisten Leute nicht, aber das passiert natürlich die ganze Zeit. Facebook analysiert die Daten, versucht die ganze Zeit Vorhersagen zu treffen und diese Vorhersagen irgendwie zu bestätigen.
Das ist ich mein die haben diese riesige Serverfarm dann nicht um Daten zu speichern, sondern sie haben sie um Daten zu analysieren.
Und das tun sie auch die ganze Zeit und das ist ihre Macht,
Das ist ihre Stärke, so. Insofern ist es doch eigentlich etwas besonders begrüßenswertes im Rahmen einer Transparenz-Offensive, dass Facebook eines seiner Forschungsergebnisse auch tatsächlich mal mit der Scientific Community teilt.
So so könnte man das jetzt auch mal äh ausdrücken. Äh wie gesagt, es wurde dann eine Linie überschritten, die sie offenbar bisher noch nicht überschritten haben. Das ist die Manipulation,
gezielte Manipulation, also ein Experiment versus ein äh quasi Experiment, zumindest ist es das erste Mal, dass so etwas ähm,
öffentlich wird. Aber jeder ähm jeder Onlineshop macht ähnliche Experimente im Kleinen,
nämlich wenn er dir anzeigt äh Kunden kauften auch. Ja, da wird auch natürlich versucht
explizit auf dich Einfluss zu nehmen und dich dazu zu bringen, etwas Weiteres zu kaufen
und dann nutzen sie anonymisiert quasi die Daten von anderen Nutzern, die das auch schon mal gekauft haben. Oder sie erfinden einfach, dass irgendein anderer Nutzer das gekauft hätte.
Ja? Ähm.
Das heißt, dass da jemand die ganze Zeit versucht, irgendwie dein Verhalten zu manipulieren, ist äh ist ganz normal.
Dafür sind diese sozialen Netzwerke da. Insofern bin ich da eigentlich bei dieser zynischen äh Auffassung dieses Sprechers äh durchaus äh mit dabei, dass er sagt, ja bist du auch hierhin gekommen? War doch klar, dass wir irgendwie mit deinen Daten äh rumfuchteln.
Und und Rum analysieren. So, das war nicht anders zu erwarten, aber ich bin da ja auch äh,
sowieso ähm relativ zynisch und es war auch nicht anders zu erwarten, dass jetzt die die Forscher, die ähm an ihren Universitäten sitzen und sich,
eben wünschen würden, auf solche Daten mal zuzugreifen, äh dass die natürlich da jetzt auch sich äh sehr, sehr erbost drüber äußern.
Weil sie natürlich niemals an solche Daten kommen würden.
Wer hat sich jetzt geäußert.
Also da wurden dann natürlich auch irgendwelche renommierten Forscher äh an Universitäten zu befragt, ob das denn ethisch wäre und die haben natürlich gesagt, was, wer's nicht.
Und ist es auch nicht, ist es auch nach nach Standards der nach denen normale ähm wissenschaftliche Forschung funktioniert, war das nicht ethisch zulässig.
Aber ähm mich interessiert ja, ich bin ja, äh wenn wenn wir von Facebook reden, äh redet ja hier äh dass der der Blinde von der Farbe, denn.
Wenn ich dich richtig verstanden habe, blenden die ja eh bestimmte Sachen aus. So.
Also du kannst nicht davon aus.
Wie wird denn euer Newsfeed ohnehin liebe Hörer,
täglich manipuliert, wenn zum Beispiel äh die neueste Lokbuchnetzpolitik nicht angezeigt wird, weil ich nicht einen Zwanni bezahlt habe. Da hättet ihr gute Laune von bekommen können, also wird täglich von Facebook,
Eure gute Laune zum schlechten gewendet, in dem euch äh Logbuch Netzpolitik nicht mit hundertprozentiger Wahrscheinlichkeit angezeigt wird.
Richtig, so ist das. So ist das. Das ist auch das ist auch irgendwie das, was mich stört so. Und ich meine, an an dem Tag, wo Twitter,
Was heißt denn an dem Tag, wo Twitter das auch macht? Den Tag gibt's bereits, ja, also bei äh ich weiß nicht, ob dir das überhaupt bewusst ist, aber in den äh wenn du die Twitter-Wapp App benutzt,
Also sozusagen die Webseite, ja, was äh wohl die allermeisten Leute auch zu meiner persönlichen Überraschung immer wieder tun,
Ähm gibt's da jetzt auch entsprechende ähm Einstellungen für.
Ja ähm
also das heißt äh Original hier Activity Reality to you it your Tweets
und man kann dann halt sich notifizierungen schicken bei einem Retweet, bei einem Favoriten oder wenn man irgendwie erwähnt wurde, ja? Oder wenn man Follower hat und so,
Und äh bei Retweet Favorit und Menschens gibt's jetzt so eine Einstellungsmöglichkeit. Also nicht nur schick mir eine Notifizierung, sondern
ein entweder bei oder das ist die äh konkrete Formulierung auf der Webseite,
Taylor for you. Via schneidern das mal so zurecht, dass das für dich ist,
Du siehst nicht alle Retweets, sondern du siehst die Retreats, von denen wir meinen, dass du sie sehen müsstest. Das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, nicht in derselben Liga wie dieses. Du siehst.
Generell du hast gar keine Möglichkeit alles zu bekommen, weil dir einfach
immer ein Prozentsatz äh vorenthalten wird, damit Leute auf Facebook, also damit Organisationen, Firmen et cetera oder reiche Einzelpersonen sich gezwungen sehen, diese Restreichweite äh zu erkaufen
ja? Das ist eigentlich ist das,
ist man da ja quasi in in Geiselhaft, ne, aber der der Trend breitet sich äh aus in diesen Netzwerken, weil das natürlich auch eine ganz, ja, man könnte es jetzt so businessmäßig, eine pfiffige Methode der Monetarisierung nennen, ja?
Jetzt haben sich alle so schön daran gewöhnt, da ihre Nachrichten drüber zu verbreiten, dann nimmst du einfach diese Funktionalität wieder raus und äh sagst ja äh ja, hier weißt du ja so, schöne Timeline haben sie da. Äh wäre doch schade, wenn die keiner
zu Gesicht bekommen würde. So.
Heißt natürlich so von der Analysemethodik her noch was anderes, das heißt vor allem, dass sie,
im Prinzip ein Profil über dich bilden und sagen, okay ähm wir bilden Hypothesen darüber,
Was für dich interessant ist und was nicht. Und durch dein Verhalten wirst du uns diese Hypothesen wiederum bestätigen.
Und dadurch werden unsere Hypothesen besser.
Das heißt, äh wir zeigen dir auch mal vielleicht ein ein äh ein ein Tweet an von jemandem, dem du gar nicht folgst und den auch niemand, den du kennst, retweetet hat, weil wir aber davon ausgehen, dass der für dich interessant ist,
Und wenn du dann irgendwie den pfaff oder sonst was, dann wissen wir, dass wir da was Gutes gemacht haben. Das Gleiche ähnliche Technik äh ist ja sehr, sehr, sehr basal
von der Logik her kommt natürlich auch zum Einsatz bei so Onlineshops, dass man eben sagt, OK, wenn
Ist das sinnvoll, wenn jemand das Buch A kauft, dem auch Buch B anzuzeigen? Das machen wir zehnmal,
wenn wir sehen, einer von denen klickt dann da drauf und kauft das vielleicht sogar, dann machen wir's noch hundertmal und wenn nicht, dann äh zeigen wir halt was anderes an
ja? Und das wäre dann das Ganze natürlich einerseits ähm horizontal quasi durch das Bücherregal machen.
Aber auch vertikal durch die Nutzer, die es gekauft haben. Das heißt, dann sagst du okay, ähm,
Wer hat jetzt ein ähnliches Interessenprofil, wie unserer äh Linus hier im Amazon, dann zeigen wir dem doch mal Sachen, die die Leute gekauft haben, die ein ähnliches Interessenprofil haben.
So und genau das kannst du natürlich bei Facebook Nutzern oder bei Twitter Nutzern auch, wenn ähm wenn eben das dein Bestreben ist. Und man kann auch tatsächlich argumentieren, ähm dass da für die Einzelne,
die Facebook-Erfahrung des Einzelnen irgendwie eine befriedigendere wird. Ja, es gibt genug Leute, die dann irgendwie,
ob äh zynisch oder äh humorvoll oder auch ganz ernst gemeint sagen, ich finde das super, wenn
Onlineshops oder Amazon oder Facebook über mich Profile bilden und mir Werbung anzeigen
mir gefällt, denn die Werbung, die mich nicht interessiert, die empfinde ich als störend und Werbung, äh die auf mich zugeschnitten ist in meinen in meiner Interesselage entspricht, die ist doch für mich interessant. Bestenfalls,
kaufe ich was Schönes, Neues, was mir mein Leben dann wieder für einen Tag äh interessanter gestaltet.
Ja. Wäre ja.
Also es ist ähm.
Ja, also ich die Aufregung über diese Facebook-Studie ist an der Stelle ähm denke ich mal schon ein bisschen übertrieben,
aber nicht, weil äh ich das jetzt besonders äh,
Also es ist nach wie vor, nach Standards unethisch, aber ähm irgendwie bei Facebook ist irgendwie so eine Sache, irgendwie so, ich weiß ja nicht. Kann das nicht vergleichen. Ihr seid irgendwie so äh.
Der der Ethik Median ist da eh anders aufgehäng.
Ja, also weißt du es halt so, du gehst da jetzt in du gehst in den Puff und beschwerst dich, dass da irgendwie auf einmal auch äh etwas stattfindet, was du jetzt äh vielleicht nicht erwartet hättest, ne?
Sehr knapp bekleidet hier die Damen.
Ne, oder dass oder dass dann irgendwie auf einmal jemand sagt, ohne Gummi kostet extra, ja? Das kannst du dann jetzt in dem in der Umgebung jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass sich das jetzt auf einmal überrascht, ja? So, ne?
So, da kannst du halt sagen, das ist nicht okay. Ja, das ist auch nicht okay. Das sollte immer mit Gummi stattfinden, aber du warst jetzt auch nicht in einer Region, wo du jetzt irgendwie erwarten solltest, dass das jetzt nicht mal doch auch mal versprochen wird.
So, ich denke, bevor wir äh noch mit weiteren Vergleichen aufkommen, die sich von dem ursprünglichen Thema zu weit entfernen. Äh schreiten wir doch voran.
Ja, O2.
Ja, O2, du, von welchem O2 ist eigentlich die Rede? Von dem Festnetz-O-To, ne?
Von dem Festnetzautorian.
Genau. Wir reden über das Festnetz O2. Das war ja bis vor nicht allzu langer Zeit äh besser bekannt
als Hansenett beziehungsweise noch besser bekannt unter Alice, dem eigentlichen Produktnamen, unter dem diese Festnetzanschlüsse verkauft wurden. Wir erinnern uns da mit,
Dame, die so im Allgemeinen Stadtbild breit plakatiert wurde, das hatte wohl den äh gewünschten Defekt und hansenet war ähm am Anfang auch nicht der schlechteste Provider, möchte ich mal so,
ganz subjektiv noch mit einschieben, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall wurde das ganze Business, glaube ich, vor zwei Jahren von O2 aufgekauft.
Okay, war mir wusste ich noch gar nicht, wusste ich gar nicht, aber äh.
O2 ist ja als Mobilfunk äh gestartet, beziehungsweise ursprünglich mal als Interkom gestartet, dann in U2 umbenannt, nachdem es halt da auch entsprechend weiter verkauft wurde.
Genau, nachdem sich irgendwann einer gefragt hat, warum kannst du nicht
wie bescheuert, also das war ja echt ein scheiß Name. Also fast noch,
als O2. Übrigens äh Otuja heute äh auch eine Randnotiz von der EU Kommission oder was oder von dem EU Wettbewerbswächtern ähm im erlaubt die
die Erlaubnis bekommen, mit E Plus zu mergen. Das nur am Rande,
Ja, auf jeden Fall O2-Festnetzkunden kommen jetzt in den Genuss des Fair-Usevorteils.
Das ist geil, ne?
Fair-Use-Vorteil, wie man darf jetzt beliebig Hollywoodfilme äh runterladen, wenn man verspricht, sie sich nur anzusehen oder was?
Vorteil. Es gibt jetzt einen faire Vorteil.
So, wir reden hier über Drosselung. Und das ist mal wieder so.
Genau.
Ich wundere mich, warum die überhaupt noch so eine Drossel jetzt äh als Thema haben. Das Ding ist doch eigentlich durch.
Was meinst du mit, ist durch?
Na, drosseln, um Festnetz.
Wieso ist das durch?
Wieso ist es durch? Na ja, weil sie ja jetzt Flatrates auf jeden Fall auch wie Flatrates, also das, was die Flatrates nennen, auch Flatrates sein müssen und das müssen sie halt explizit Drosselverträger äh anbieten.
Da wo vorher Flatriz warten, aber es bezieht sich jetzt wahrscheinlich, ich kenne jetzt die Quelle deiner Meldung hier nicht, aber das bezieht sich jetzt dann wahrscheinlich auf günstigere, neu,
Anschlüsse.
Nee, sie haben, also es ist relativ einfach, sie sagen leider finde ich jetzt die Seite äh.
Ich habe nur eine Hilfeseite, also aber ich hab's mir aber gemerkt. Sie sagen ähm laut Bundesnetzagentur nutzt der Durchschnittsnutzer einundzwanzig Gigabyte Internet im Monat.
So und wer diese Durchschnittsnutzung.
Sehr stark überschreitet, nämlich um den Faktor vierzehn. Und dreihundert Gigabyte im Monat braucht. Und diese dreihundert Gigabyte in drei aufeinanderfolgenden Monaten.
Überschreitet. Dem werden wir ab dem vierten Monat, in dem er das tut.
Die Finger abhacken.
Wieder nach den dreihundert Gigabyte eine Drossel,
auf äh zweitausend Kilobit reinwürgen.
Also zwei Megabit.
Zwei Mbit, ja. So,
Wenn mehrere Personen in ihrem Haushalt surfen, rechnen sie den Verbrauch bitte je Person. So und jetzt sagen sie okay und das heißt, wir drosseln bei jemandem, der wirklich lange, nämlich immerhin ein Vierteljahr.
Jedes Mal diese Grenze reißt. Und wenn das der Fall ist.
Dann kann er trotzdem diese Grenze bis zu dieser Grenze äh unbegrenzt äh surfen äh und dann erst wird der gedrosselt. Und wenn das, wenn wir ihn dann drosseln, kann er sich nochmal hundert zusätzliche Gig für einen Fünfer kaufen,
oder die diese Drossel ganz loswerden für zusätzliche fünfzehn Euro.
Und diese Option gibt's jeweils ohne eine großartige äh Kündigungsfrist. Das heißt, kannst du einmal im Monat machen, also wie.
So ähnlich wie das ähm,
Wie das jetzt schon im Mobilfunk ist, dass sie sagen, ey, du hast hier deine, dein vereinbartes Volumen überschritten. Ab jetzt geht's langsam weiter. Äh wenn du jetzt irgendwie auf diese SMS mit Ja antwortest, kriegst du für einmalig so und so viel Euro äh nochmal.
Zweihundertfünfzig MB oder sowas und dann irgendwann schreiben sie dir, hör mal, du hast das jetzt drei Monate in Folge gemacht, willst du nicht einfach eh fünfhundert dazu buchen oder so, ne?
Ähm so macht das zumindest mein äh Mobil Provider, hat's dann auch irgendwann mit Erfolg geschafft, dass ich dann irgendwann gesagt habe, okay, ich gebe euch dauerhaft einen Fünfer mehr.
So. Ja, jetzt ist erstmal dazu zu sagen.
Das Ganze den Kunden als Vorteil zu verkaufen ist natürlich eine sehr, sehr äh zynische, aber auch sehr geschickte äh Marketingstrategie. Der Fair-Use-Vorteil, den du jetzt hast, ja, ich meine.
Fair-Use ist eine eine Floskel oder ein Begriff Begriffspaar, das natürlich aus einer ganz anderen aus einer ganz anderen Ecke kommt, ne. Ähm.
Und da jetzt also wie gesagt, für den einzelnen Nutzer ist es nach wie vor ein Nachteil. Im Vergleich zu dem, was die Deutsche Telekom äh vorhat,
ist es natürlich aber schon eine recht humane Herangehensweise. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was mein ich kann nochmal kurz schauen, ich kriege das ja regelmäßig mitgeteilt.
Was mein Verbrauch ist. Steht's.
Also wo ich ja auch finde, wo sie sich dann doch äh trotz allem auf jeden Fall in den Fuß schießen ist,
es gelingt ihnen auch ein relativ noch relativ unkompliziertes Produkt,
DSL Flatrate-Anschluss, ja? Das war bisher also nicht, dass man da beim Bestellen nicht eine Menge falsch machen kann, aber wenn du es erstmal hast und weißt, was du da monatlich zahlst, dann
ist das für dich irgendwie eine kalkulierbare Größe? Aber durch solche Sachen äh komplizieren sie wieder das Ganze,
Einfach immer wieder der Meinung bin, auch im Mobilfunk im Übrigen,
Also die Tatsache, dass einfach alles so kompliziert ist, hält so dermaßen viele Leute davon ab, einfach mal irgendwas zu kaufen
weil einfach in diesem ganzen Klauseln und Einschränkungen und Fußnoten und so und sich einfach verliert wie im Dickicht und dann irgendwann das Gefühl hat, ich
mich dem überhaupt nicht nähern. Also mir geht es zum Beispiel so, weiß nicht wie äh du da so drauf bist, aber ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es auch noch einigen anderen so geht.
Bei den Tarifen äh klicke ich doch eh immer den fettesten.
Aber.
Aber wenn's ich meine äh
wenn's denen überhaupt gibt, ne, aber wenn du halt jetzt ein Jahr unser Fettester ist aber auch hier mit irgendwie Sternchen eins und dann äh sie dürfen aber nur bei irgendwie durchschnittlicher Mondscheindauer äh soundso viel äh geteilt durch die aktuelle Verkündung,
des BSCs, der der Sicherheitsgefahr, ja, zum Quadrat und das Ganze mal angenommener, äh, Durchschnittsnutzung, äh, eines Normalusers,
da verlierst du dich doch einfach so da blickt doch kein Mensch mehr durch.
Na, sie sie nennen halt ihre Tarife jetzt all in S, M und L.
Ich meine, okay, also aber das ist jetzt nicht der Punkt. Also, ich denke, der der Punkt bei dieser Sache ist, dass als damals die Telekom vormarschierte mit dieser Drosselsache, wurde auch vorhergesagt, okay, das werden jetzt andere machen.
Und andere machen's jetzt auch. Und O2 zieht jetzt eben nach und zieht jetzt damit effektiv bei bei ihnen sagen sie jetzt also der monatliche Preis für so einen VDSL fünfzig.
Ist eben dreißig Euro und da machen wir ab dreihundert machen wir den Sack zu und ziehen dich irgendwie zurück in.
Ins, weiß ich nicht, in zehn Jahren zurück in Bandbreiten der Bandbreite und wenn du halt einen unlimitierten VDSL-Anschluss haben möchtest,
kostet er eben einfach mal fünfzig Prozent mehr, nämlich statt dreißig Euro im Monat fünfundvierzig Euro im Monat.
Und das ist natürlich eigentlich eine versteckte Preiserhöhung gegenüber dem, was sie vorher gemacht haben.
Unter der Annahme, dass der unbegrenzte, dass der bisher unbegrenzte VDSL-Tarif eben auch dreißig Euro gekostet hat, wovon ich ausgehen würde, denn so viel zahle ich auch.
Ja, Linus, gibt's da noch irgendwas äh anzumerken?
Ja, also ich, es ist nicht es ist schon, also ich find's sehr, ich find's sehr.
Geschickt, wie sie's bezeichnen, also den Leuten eine Leistung wegzunehmen und die als das als Vorteil zu bezeichnen ist natürlich schon äh sehr ähm.
Sehr äh witzig. Andererseits haben sie wenigstens ein Modell da irgendwie um das ähm.
Um dir ein Ausweg zu erlauben aus dieser Drosselung, auch in den unlimitierten Bereich.
Ich finde dreihundert Gig ist tatsächlich jetzt eine Grenze, die nicht so viele reisen werden.
Das wird sie auch bald ändern. Aber ich kann dir sagen, so eine Fußball-WM zum Beispiel, da dürfte ganz schön was zusammengekommen sein bei den Leuten, die das irgendwie nicht über Fernsehen geschaut haben.
Jetzt die Gelegenheit gehabt, bei O2 ähm einmalig auf unlimited zu schalten für fünfzehn mehr.
Also das geht schon, aber natürlich klar, die,
Das Problem bei den Drosseln ist ja nicht, dass sie dass sie drosseln, okay, ich meine, das macht den den äh den den Tarif für einige Nutzer unattraktiver. Das Problem ist eben, wenn sie anfangen.
Einzelne Dienste aus diesen Drosselkontingent herauszunehmen und das ist ja eben der zweite Schritt äh mit dem da eben genau zu rechnen ist, wenn so etwas gemacht wird. Und insofern
Wenn sie ihr Tarifmodell ändern in die Form, dann ist finde ich das,
ist das okay, das sei eben, sei ihnen unbenommen, aber problematisch und laut äh werde ich da erst, wenn sie äh Dinge davon ausnehmen.
Denke, das ist der entscheidende Punkt. Und da geht die Reise hin und das natürlich auch scheiße.
Ja
Muss man jetzt glaube ich nicht dazu sagen.
Nee, ich denke auch.
Genau. Kommen wir äh zum zum äh innenpolitischen äh Drama Zentrum, dem äh,
Ausschuss zur Untersuchung der NSA Skandalvorwürfe. Ich weiß gar nicht, was es denn da offizielle Titel eigentlich von diesem Ausschuss.
Ich hatte da, ich hatte das nochmal, ich hatte das auch mehrmals zusammen kopiert, warte mal, ich glaube, das steht hier in einem der Links, die ich dazu gesammelt habe. Ähm,
Hoffen wir mal, dass es da steht. Es ist der Untersuchungsausschuss für Überwachungs- und Geheimdienst-Affäre.
Aha. Na ja, den meinte ich.
Genau. Der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss.
Genau und da gab's eine Anhörung ähm von Experten.
Technischen Fragen.
Technischen Fragen und äh ja, da waren dann auch einige Experten äh anwesend. Unter anderem auch äh Frank Rieger vom CCC.
Ja, man kann, glaube ich, sagen, es waren zwei Experten anwesend. Ja, da war noch ein war noch Sandro Geigen war auch da.
Und ähm du hast auch einen Mitschnitt äh glaube ich äh online gestellt, sehe ich das richtig?
Ja, also es ist, es war so, ich schuldete Frank ein bisschen was, weil ich mich ähm über seinen Bart äh auf Twitter lustig gemacht habe, den er äh trug. Und ähm,
es dann irgendwie auf Twitter keine inhaltliche Debatte zu dieser Anhörung gab, die live gestreamt wurde und äh das wurde dann mir zur Last gelegt. Und als kleine Entschädigung habe ich dann äh das Video von dieser Anhörung genommen und habe ähm,
nur Franksäußerungen hintereinander geschnitten, ähm sodass man äh diese drei oder vierstündige Anhörung da dann in auf eine Stunde zusammen kondensiert, ähm.
Sehen und hören kann.
Das war ganz unterhaltsam.
Das war ne das also bei Frank, Frank ähm ist da ja wirklich ähm sehr informiert zu diesem Thema
und äh das war sehr interessant, was er dort auch noch mal so zusammengefasst hat für die Ausschussmitglieder. Und deswegen habe ich da einmal ein Video, den Videozusammenschnitt auf YouTube gestellt und auch ein Audiozusammenschnitt gemacht und die haben, die sind beide sehr schön, weil
ähm wenn der Frank fertig ist, dann sagt immer der Patrick äh Sensburg, der diesem Ausschuss ja vorsitzt, ähm,
Herr Rieker und wenn Frank dran ist, dann,
sagt er als erstes immer ja und spricht dann. Und wenn man diesen Audiozusammenschnitt hat, dann redet halt Frank und dann sagt irgendwann zwischendurch, äh der Patrick Sensburg,
Danke Herr Rieger und Frank sagt ja und spricht dann weiter. Das ist ganz schön. Also das kann man sich ganz gut anhören.
So, da hat dann eben so verschiedene Fragen der Stellung genommen. Die Fragen ähm,
sind teilweise äh detaillierter als das äh bei meiner Anhörung war vor äh vor ein paar Wochen vorher im Bundestagsausschuss digitale Agenda. Ähm.
Weil sie sich eben konkret auf die auf die Tätigkeiten der Geheimdienste äh beziehen. Und ja, Frank hat da insgesamt so einen Redeanteil von etwas über einer Stunde gehabt, kann man sich kann man sich sehr gut,
anhören. Das sei an dieser Stelle nochmal empfohlen, haben wir, wie gesagt, verlinkt,
gleichzeitig tut sich in diesem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss ja aber auch einiges. Wir erinnern uns ja, dass ähm.
Der letzte Stand war das äh glaube ich, den wir berichtet haben, dass äh sich die,
die die äh Regierungsfraktion, die diesen Untersuchungsausschuss ja zahlenmäßig auch bestimmt ähm,
dagegen wehrt Snowden da irgendwie einzuladen
oder ihm irgendwie entgegenzukommen. Sie wollen ihn ja irgendwie dazu zwingen, ohne irgendwelche Gegenleistungen ähm eine äh Videoschalte mit ihnen zu machen und dann als Zeuge dort auszusagen, ähm,
woraufhin ja jetzt Edwards Nonne gesagt hat, also tut mir leid Freunde oder beziehungsweise Wolfgang Kahlek äh im Auftrag von gesagt hat, Entschuldigung, was ihr wollt ist eine Zeugenaussage, nicht irgendwie eine Grußbotschaft und ähm,
das können, können wir hier, äh können wir hier vom Oskar aus mit einer Videobotschaft nicht machen.
So und jetzt haben äh Linke und Grüne angekündigt, dass sie gemeinsam beim Bundesverfassungsgericht eine Klage einreichen wollen,
Und zwar, weil Rot-Schwarz, also CDU und SPD die Arbeit des Ausschusses behindern und Sabotieren, denn,
Sie haben ja einen Beschluss in diesem Ausschuss, dass Sie Snowden befragen wollen.
Aber die äh SPD und CDU abgesandt in diesem Untersuchungsausschuss, das ja nun verhindern,
und der Verdacht, der da nahe liegt und das denke ich, da haben sie einen validen Punkt, dass die Regierung das im Prinzip diktiert und die Regierung ist ja zu teilen eben auch Ziel,
oder Objektes dieses Untersuchungsausschusses, denn die Regierung hat die Bundesregierung hat ja schon sehr weit vorher bekannt gegeben, dass eine,
Vernehmungs-Nones in Deutschland nicht stattfinden wird.
Das wäre aber eben eigentlich Sache dieses Untersuchungsausschusses gewesen. Und das äh nehmen Linke und Grüne jetzt zum Anlass, damals zu prüfen, ob sie
da nicht vor das äh Bundesverfassungsgericht ziehen können, um da eine entsprechende Vernehmung zu erzwingen.
Weil es ja für solche Ausschüsse eine Pflicht der Amtshilfe äh gibt und eine Pflicht der zur Aufklärung für die Ausschussmehrheit.
Genau, jetzt ist mir das Problem, dass nach Strafprozessordnung Paragraph zweihundertsiebenundvierzig A.
Die Videobefragung eines zeugen möglich ist, wenn die dringende Gefahr eines schwerwiegendes, schwerwiegenden Nachteils für das Wohl des Zeugen besteht.
So und jetzt ist natürlich interessant, was dir schwerwiegende Nachteil für das Wohl des Zeugen ist. Das heißt, die Bundesregierung kann sich aus der Nummer,
Zweifelsfall raus, Lawinenern, indem sie äh eben nochmals äh betonen, dass sie für die Sicherheit.
Snodens auf deutschem Boden nicht garantieren können, was ja an sich schon sehr, sehr peinlich ist, äh wenn sie das so sagen.
Andererseits kann man dann natürlich sagen
eine Videovernehmung wäre für schwer besonders schwerwiegende Nachteil für das Wohl des Zeugen Snowden, weil er dann im Zweifelsfall Ärger mit seinen russischen momentanen Gastgebern bekommt.
Die ja immer noch als als kleine Auflage des Asyls haben, dass sie sagen, mach uns aber jetzt erstmal keinen größeren Ärger mehr.
Ähm insofern habe ich nach meinem jetzigen Kenntnisstand scheint diese Beschwerde vor dem äh Bundesverfassungsgericht dann,
Doch, wahrscheinlich eher auf auf relativ dünnem Eis zu stehen, wenn sie eine solche Anstrengung wollen.
Zu begrüßen wäre es natürlich trotzdem und äh es ist grundsätzlich immer zu begrüßen, äh wenn äh Menschen,
sich zusammentun, um ihr möglichstes zu tun, um dieser Farce in irgendeiner Form ein Ende zu bereiten und dieser NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss ist ja jetzt eine Farce, die wir seit einiger Zeit beobachten
und das ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt, äh wenn da jetzt mal langsam jemand auf den Tisch haut.
Ja
Also mir sind halt die Instrumente da auch nicht so richtig klar, aber es scheint einfach grundsätzlich gar keinen politischen äh Willen zu geben, da wirklich irgendwas Nennenswertes aufzudecken. Einfach weil sie zwar,
Also auf mich macht es immer so den Eindruck, sie haben sicherlich schon die Erwartung, dass dass sich da eigentlich eine ganze Menge aufdecken ließe, ja
Vielleicht wäre manches auch irgendwie im eigenen Sinne so, weil ich denke, dass auch äh die Politik nicht unbedingt jetzt
sich immer so wohl fühlt da äh von den Geheimdiensten so, so eine Geiselhaft genommen zu werden. Aber das ist vor allem auch,
Das ist jetzt eine reine subjektive Betrachtung von mir. Ich kann das äh mit nichts äh untermauern, ja, aber das ist meiner Auffassung nach,
schon eher dieser internationale Druck, sprich der Druck aus den USA ist der einfach sozusagen politisch äh geprägt ihn irgendwie äh da ausreichend äh Respekt abverlangt. So nach dem Motto,
seht mal zu, dass ihr das verhindert bekommt. So, weil wenn ihr es nicht verhindert bekommt, dann machen wir euch auch so dermaßen vielen Ebenen Stress. Da seht ihr keine Sonne mehr.
Ja und ich weiß, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das in den letzten äh Sendungen, ob wir das da schon besprochen hatten. Es gibt auch einen Anlass dazu, also es gibt auf zwei Ebenen Anlass dazu.
Ähm die ja, wollte ich ja gerade sagen, äh zu fürchten, äh dass die.
Norden da aussagt. Einerseits, weil die amerikanische Regierung da sicherlich sich einige äh Konsequenzen,
zu einfallen lassen wird, die in irgendeiner Form ein
ähm politischen Nachteil nach sich ziehen werden oder einen strategischen Nachteil nach sich ziehen werden. Andererseits haben wir aber,
in den letzten Wochen sehr viel gelernt über die Zusammenarbeit. Sowohl der Bundesregierung und der US-Regierung, als auch ihrer Geheimdienste.
Und ich hatte ja da mehrmals schon dann auch im,
auf den auf dem medialen Ebene, die mir da zur Verfügung gestellt wurde. Darauf hingewiesen, dass der Frank-Walter Steinmeier da seit mindestens zehn Jahren Mitwisser und Mittäter ist.
Ja und äh ich bin mir,
relativ gespannt, was äh ein AdWord Snowden da über die Zusammenarbeit zwischen den Diensten in einem solchen Untersuchungsausschuss erzählen könnte. Ich bin mir,
also die Motivationen irgendwie dafür zu sorgen, dass der Snowden möglichst nicht aussagt, sind da sicherlich mannigfach für die äh Bundesregierung.
Ja, sehe ich ähnlich.
Und insofern finde ich das dann äh auch sehr begrüßenswert, wenn dann die Opposition sagt, nee Freunde, jetzt hauen wir mal auf den Tisch und jetzt sehen wir mal zu, dass wir das Ganze hier jetzt mal langsam zum ähm.
Auf auf eine vernünftige Bahn bringen, weil die Opposition kann sich ja jetzt auch nicht irgendwie auf weitere Monate irgendwie in diesem NSA Untersuchungsausschuss da so verarschen lassen von diesen Hampelmännern,
Also das geht ja wirklich nicht. Da kannst du ja echt nicht anschauen.
Ich freue mich wie wie das Theater aussehen äh ausgesehen hätte, wenn wir jetzt in eine rot-grüne Regierung gehabt hätten.
Ähm sicherlich genauso. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es da einen großen Unterschied gegeben hätte.
Bestimmt. Also du hältst nicht so eine äh schwarz-roten Block, der gesagt hätte, das geht nicht, sondern du hättest
quasi die CDU ja dann trotzdem noch ein Boot. Also das kann kann mir keiner,
dass die CDU an der Stelle irgendwie auf einmal äh so so einen linken Kurs fährt, am besten noch mit den Linken zusammen in der Opposition, ja? Wir fordern jetzt hier rückhaltlose Aufklärung.
Nee, nee, das stimmt. Also im.
Nie und nimmer, ja.
Das stimmt. Das heißt, die Fronten werden wahrscheinlich genau gleich verlaufen, nämlich SPD und CDU irgendwie beschwichtigen. Ja, schau mal da, äh ein Sommerloch oder so und.
Ja, aber die Grünen werden sicherlich auch auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise eingenordet. In dem Moment, wo sie selber Teil der Regierung sind und dann einfach diesen äh unmittelbaren Druck im Kabinett einfach auch mitbekommen.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, da ist die Frage, wie weit die da jetzt inzwischen auch schon durch ihre Regierungsbeteiligung vorbelastet sind mit mit mit Mitwissen und Mittäterschaften.
Rumhaltest, deswegen, also ich, wie auch immer. Es ist auch alles äh Hypothese und äh was wäre wenn? Spielt letzten Endes eigentlich äh keine Rolle, aber wir werden das einfach weiter beobachten, was da an Informationen noch äh hochkommt und wie sich das alles so entwickelt und
was man so alles so glauben kann, wie es denn nun eigentlich äh wirklich ist, äh finden wieder dieses schöne Ding ein mit der Wahrheit, ja. Es gibt ja irgendwie wie viel Wahrheiten gibt's vier?
Das war's irgendwie berichtet wurde, was in der Zeitung steht irgendwie. Äh.
Das, was wirklich geschah, also.
Das, was wirklich geschah. Das waren jetzt nur drei. Ich krieg's nicht mehr zusammen. Es ist äh ist schon zu früh.
Man merkt, ist äh WM und Tim ist äh guckst du, guckst du eigentlich da nebenbei gerade wieder im Fußballspiel oder was?
Nee, läuft gerade keins.
Also wir haben noch zwei kleine Kurzmeldungen am Ende des äh des des Tages. Und zwar.
Zwei, oder? Wenn ich die richtig zähle. Nee, drei, drei.
Nö, ich drei.
Dresden ist jetzt DM City.
Ja, ja.
Ja, das ist mir neu. Was was ist das? Äh, wie steht das jetzt auch schon so am Hauptbahnhof, irgendwie auf so Schildern? Äh nach Hannover fährst, da steht die Messe statt.
Die.
Ja. Nee, ähm Sachsen hat äh als eines der ersten Bundesländer dann auch ein E-Government äh Gesetz äh verabschiedet. Ähm,
und äh klärt darin dann auch eben den Verzicht auf äh für bestimmte Behördengänge notwendige Unterschriften. Ähm.
Und in Zukunft soll dann eben auf die,
D Mail und auf die EID Funktion des neuen Personalausweises gesetzt werden. Ich bin so ein bisschen müde, diese D-Mail Problematik immer wieder zusammenzufassen, aber ich mach's nochmal ganz kurz, ähm,
ein Verfahren, was jetzt nicht irgendwie nennenswertsicherer ist als als E-Mail und ähm.
Das Hauptproblem ist eben dann auch diese die Signatur unter Willensbekundungen, die dann eben mit dieser D-Mail wegfällt und der aber dann auch kein äh,
kein äh kryptografisches Äquivalent
gegeben wird, sondern der Anbieter unterschreibt dann die D-Mail für dich und deswegen gilt sie als von dir unterschrieben. Auch hier wieder die den Nutz der des Nutzen der EID Funktion des äh neuen Personalausweises,
dass eben äh
keine Signatur ist, sondern eben nur das Zeigen des Personalausweises. Also da wird äh grade entsprechend der dem Ziel des Egovermittles, was ja letztes Jahr in Kraft getreten ist,
eine Menge Sicherheitsniveau abgebaut, was wir bisher verlangt haben.
Und Dresden möchte da jetzt voranschreiten und aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat sich offensichtlich äh haben sich die Dresdner Behörden dazu breit schlagen lassen. An dieser Marketing und Werbekampagne für äh,
Anbieter teilzunehmen. Ist eigentlich ziemlich peinlich für für die Stadt. Ähm,
Das ARD Mittagsmagazin hat mich da äh meinen Senf zugeben lassen.
Da musstest du nicht ganz so früh aufstehen.
Nee, die ja, die kamen am Vortag. Äh ähm die kam am Nachmittag vorbei
bin da mit diesen Fernsehbeiträgen ja, also das ist irgendwie eine etwas enttäuschende Erfahrung immer. Also man erklärt denen dann so viel, das war echt interessant, also diese als ich dann,
Mit diesem ARD-Team da saß und äh so meine meine Sachen zu D-Mail erzählte,
dann sagt er quasi mitten im Take sagte der Kameramann so.
Und versaute damit quasi die Aufnahme. Also der war der der Kameramann, der wirklich darauf geschult ist, irgendwie Sachen zu filmen und die Fresse zu halten,
mittendrin bei etwas, was ich sagte. Dann so gesagt, ehrlich.
Musste ich das nochmal neu sagen.
Oh Gott, und beim zweiten Mal ist es nie so gut.
Ja genau, der verabschiedete sich dann aber mit den Worten ähm ich kündige jetzt sofort mein Konto.
Der hatte sich nämlich inzwischen schon mit so mit so einem ähm mit so einem Zalando-Gutschein oder oder irgendeiner fünftausend Lufthansa-Meilen oder wie auch immer, was man alles kriegt, wenn man.
Was liegt das jetzt schon ein Burger bei oder was? Also.
Ja ja, die haben ja schon
Das machen sie ja schon seit seit Monaten irgendwie, dass sie da das stark bewerben, irgendwie kriegst du irgendwelche Einkaufsgutscheine, so, ich glaube, zwanzig Euro in der, in der Region, Amazon oder Zalando und irgendwie
oder zweitausend Lufthansa-Meilen oder wat da auch immer haben. Jetzt kriegst irgendwas kriegst du. Ähm freiwillig macht das eben keiner, ne? Und dann hatten wir,
verwiesen, diese äh Eins und Eins war das, glaube ich, nee, Web DE, die da so eher auf die Druckerkolonnentour kamen,
äh also die die versuchen da alles, ne. Und ähm er war offensichtlich ein Opfer davon, hatte auch in seinem Leben noch keine D-Mail,
gesendet oder empfangen und weil's eben hatte jetzt so ein Konto und was ich da überhaupt nicht klar, was er für einen Mist sich da hatte, aufschwätzen lassen. Also der verabschiedete sich mit den Worten.
Äh ja, da äh wird er sofort wieder los. Also da habe ich schon mal einen einen Menschen offensichtlich überzeugt mit meinen Ausführungen. In dem Beitrag selber war das dann eher natürlich ähm
so zusammengekürzt auf einen Kritikpunkt und den fand ich jetzt nicht so würzig. Äh ich glaube, da hatte ich äh einige einige einige,
Äußerungen dann noch mit in die in die Kamera gesagt.
Aber aber schön finde ich in diesem in diesem Mittagsmagazin Beitrag wieder in einem Schluss, so ein Laptop irgendwie direkt ans Finanzamt geschickt wird, auf dem dann großartige NSA-Monitoren, die weiß Aufkleber hinten draufklebt.
Ja, aber das ist so, das scheint so dieses Niveau zu sein, ne, wo.
Was ich sehr schön finde, ist der der Furzzi von der Telekom sagt in diesem Beitrag und das ist halt echt schön, da sollte man ihn eigentlich äh auch für verklagen oder was. Ähm,
D-Mail ist Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt,
Wir entschlüsseln sie nur für ein ganz kurzen Moment. Und dann fangen sie wieder an mit diesem Bullshit, äh dass sie irgendwie ein Bierenscan dadrüber machen oder so, ne. Also das ist ähm
Ja, wie gesagt, ich werde da ein bisschen müde. Und es gibt ja auch die Aufzeichnungen meines Vortrags zu dem Thema, wer das immer noch nicht sich damit ausreichend äh auseinandergesetzt fühlt, kann sich den gerne auf YouTube anschauen.
Ach so und dann aber genau, das muss man noch sagen, dieser Mittagsmagazinbeitrag war also so ja, da war ich ein bisschen enttäuscht, dass da der Kritik nicht mehr Raum oder der die Kritik nicht noch,
ausführlicher betrachtet wurde. Ähm aber ich hatte in der gleichen Woche war auch ein Team von RTL aktuell da und da bin ich also sehr auf sehr.
Da bin ich offensichtlich am Ende in einem mehr oder weniger Werbevideo zu E-Mail Made in Germany gelandet. Da war ich also nochmal sehr viel enttäuschter.
Da war ich, war ich ja sehr enttäuscht. Da habe ich dann irgendwie meine ganze Kritik an an E-Mail made in Germany denen erzählt und am Ende war dann irgendwie auch so
Ja, so der der lahmste Punkt irgendwie noch mit drin. Na ja, keine Ahnung. Also RTL aktuell, glaube ich, denen antworte ich erstmal nicht mehr auf Anfragen.
Mittagsmagazin schon.
Ja, na, wenn du da enttäuscht warst, frage ich mich natürlich ernsthaft, was da in der Erwartungshaltung vorher gewesen ist. Ja, ja.
Aktuell. Ich habe gedacht, den habe ich halt richtig einen vom Leder gelassen und ich habe gedacht, die Äußerung, bei der ich am meisten Schaum vorm Mund habe, äh werden sie nehmen,
Aber äh war eben genau umgekehrt. Die haben halt dann so die die moderateste äh,
Äußerungen. Wir gucken mal, wie das Mikrofon auspegelt genommen. Na ja, ist auch egal. Ach. Komm, ja.
So was gelernt, ne? Überall unsere Medienrealität.
Realität habe ich gestern in einer in einer wunderbaren Anfrage. Ich weiß, wie kann ich das denn ähm also das war auch Privatfernsehen.
Und die suchten also nach einem Hacker und hatten also bestimmte Vorstellungen, äh was der Hacker ihn denn hacken sollte.
Ah, mit Maske oder ohne?
Ja
Also das war echt geil. Die haben gesagt, ja wir haben so zwei Drehtage und wir haben uns überlegt, du könntest ja äh das Hecken und das Hecken und ein Polizeiauto hacken und,
völlig abstruse Vorstellung, was da irgendwie zu hacken wäre, ja und dann äh sagten sie, ja und ihnen wäre natürlich auch klar, dass das äh alles gar nicht legal wäre
und ähm da würden hätten sie sich aber auch schon Gedanken zu gemacht, weil man könnte ja den Protagonisten ähm dann in der in der Aufzeichnung unkenntlich machen
und man könnte ja nach dem Hack dann auch äh bei den Behörden anrufen, um ihnen zu sagen, dass das nur ein Test war, also was von wirr. Es war auch ähm ein ein Magazin aus dem Privatfernsehen. Also da
laut drüber gelacht, aber ähm ja ähm.
Das ist ja wirklich äh unfassbar irgendwie.
Es fiel dann unter ähm unter gelesen, gelacht, gelocht, äh abgeheftet.
Moment, äh, kleinen Moment. Äh, Moment. Hallo? Hallo?
Ah, ja. Ah okay. Ja, das waren jetzt die Neunziger, die wollten ihr Drehbuch äh zurück haben.
Ui. Ja, das war, ach so, genau, der das Drehbuch war natürlich vollständig über die gesamte es ist echt.
Aber so so Anfragen kommen eigentlich relativ häufig. Aber die feiere ich jetzt so besonders witzig, weil auch so, wir rufen danach bei den Behörden an und sagen, das war nur ein Spaß. Also überhaupt allein die Idee, als wenn.
Lass uns weiter vorspulen Linus.
Zu kicken. Ja, also was nicht. Okay. Wir erinnern.
Noch hier Bundestag und.
Bundestag und ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir letzte Woche das schon erzählt hatten.
Dass sie ihr Internet darüber beziehen, ja. Ach.
Genau, aber jetzt nicht mehr. Sie wollen äh das wird jetzt zum schnellstmöglichen Zeitpunkt gekündigt, irgendwie Ende zweitausendfünfzehn schon.
Mhm. Wirklich. Hatten sie da etwas, ein etwas länger laufenden Vertrag?
Ja da die Zusammenarbeit war dann wohl offensichtlich ein bisschen länger. Und äh.
Es geht ja bei sowas dann eh nur um die Headline.
Aber was ich noch viel geiler fand, war dann so eine äh Meldung, was Verizen noch macht. Denn Ryzen wartet die des Bundesarbeitsministeriums.
Jetzt wissen natürlich viele nicht, was ein ist.
Ja, vor allem, was man da warten muss.
Ja äh da haben sie jetzt also ich stelle äh kurz erklären, was ein ASA talken ist. Bei besonders hoch, also bei besonders sicherheitskritischen Anmeldevorgängen.
Zum Beispiel bei sowas wie
dem Managementzugang zu kritischer Infrastruktur oder so, belässt man es nicht bei einem einzelnen Passwort und einem Nutzernamen, den jetzt, sage ich mal, die Menschen brauchen, um um da dazu Zugang zu bekommen, sondern
sie brauchen einen zweiten Faktor. Das machen eure Banken zum Beispiel, wenn sie euch eine SMS schicken und,
ne und eure.
Oder auch die Tarnliste war im Prinzip schon genau dasselbe äh Modell.
Genau, äh also zweiter Faktor heißt zum Einloggen muss man etwas haben und etwas wissen,
ist so das, was man da häufig macht. Und aus einer aus der Security-Perspektive ist es deshalb interessant, weil sich dann das, was beim Einloggen übertragen wird,
jedes Mal unterscheidet. Das heißt, selbst jemand, der, sage ich mal, den Computer vollständig trojanisiert hat und alles, was derjenige bei der Anmeldung eingibt.
Mitschneiden kann, kann dann nicht bei einem zweiten Mal sich auch dort authentifizieren, ja? Das heißt, ich kann
man kann zwar mein Online-Banking-Passwort mit sniffen und man kann auch die TAN mit Sniffen, die ich eingebe, aber man kann mit diesem Wissen nicht eine zweite Transaktion auslösen. Und ähnliches macht man eben bei der äh
bei der Anmeldung zu kritischen äh kritischen Systemen.
Vielleicht mal ein einfacheres Beispiel, ja, äh du hast es ja korrekt beschrieben, aber äh wer immer noch nicht äh den den Groschen hat, also man kann das zum Beispiel bei
Bei Dropbox kann man das machen, wenn man auf sein Dropbox-Account zugreifen will, dass man da nicht nur mit Username Passwort rankommt, ja, also stell mal vor, du liegst irgendwie deine Festplatten, keine Ahnung, irgendein Virus kommt angelaufen et cetera
und äh dein Passwort ist in irgendeiner Form auch vakant oder wurde mal mitgeschnitten, ähm kann man halt das so einstellen, dass man eben
mit einem dass man noch einen zweiten Code eingeben muss und der wird dann halt von so einer Applikation erzeugt und der gilt immer nur für dreißig Sekunden
alle dreißig Sekunden änderte sich und wenn man sich halt einloggt, muss man eben den Code angeben, der genau in dem Moment angezeigt wird. Und dreißig Sekunden später ist die,
ein Mitschneiden dieses kurzes sozusagen Quatsch, weil der einfach nach drei Sekunden wieder weg ist. Man müsste eigentlich.
Krypto dahinter äh haben, aber die wird halt nicht als solche übertragen.
Genau und da kommt der interessante Punkt. Ähm um das Ganze jetzt in Hochsicherheitsbereich zu überführen, also wenn das irgendwie per SMS oder App ist, dann wird's natürlich auch wieder anfällig für entsprechende Smartphoneviren oder so, ne, oder auch Angriffe auf das Mobilfunknetz.
Und eben einen Hochsicherheitsbereich,
oder was heißt Hochsicherheitsbereich? In im vernünftigen Sicherheitsbereich setzt man dann eben auf das sind so kleine Schlüsselanhänger.
Und die machen im Prinzip genau das. Die zeigen alle paar äh alle Dollar-Zeiteinheit, einen anderen Code an. Und der ist dann, weiß ich nicht, vier oder sechsstellig oder so, ne.
Sechsstellig in der Regel und dreißig Sekunden, das ist, glaube ich, so der übliche Tanzslot.
So und jetzt ist die Frage, jetzt gibt es quasi zwischen diesem Token,
und dem System gegenüber dem du dich authentifizieren muss. Eine Art synchronisierung. Die haben ein geteiltes Wissen, nämlich sie kennen die chaotische Funktion,
die sie, ihr die sie zwei Sachen vereinfacht reingeben, nämlich die aktuelle Zeit.
Und eine lang ein langes Basisgeheimnis. Und daraus ergibt sich dann alle dreißig Sekunden dieser neue,
token.
Genau, dieses Basisgeheimnis, das muss man einmal bei einer, bei der Einrichtung erhält man das, liegt das in dieses äh entweder in diesen Schlüsselanhänger oder man kann das halt auch auf so einer, aufm Smartphone, auf einer App.
Auf einer geringeren Sicherheitsstufe eben in so eine App packen und,
wenn man's eben wenn man es besonders sicher haben will, dann nutzt man eben diese RSA. Wie gesagt, kleine dedizierte Hardware, die nichts anderes macht, als einfach nur immer wieder diesen Mist anzeigen. So und in diesem ISA-Talken
muss aber einmal das Grundgeheimnis rein, nämlich dieser dieser Code,
den der und das Zielsystem eben teilen und aus dem sie dann jeweils alle dreißig Sekunden den in zu diesem Zeitpunkt gültigen Token errechnen.
Und wenn ich in der Lage bin, diesen Key, der dem zweiten, diesen ganzen Token zusammen zu Grunde liegt.
Wenn ich den also habe, dann kann ich natürlich auch jeden einzelnen Token, den dieser Token jemals anzeigen wird, berechnen.
Und wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, dann hat für Ryzen genau das gemacht, nämlich diese Geheimnisse auf die. Beziehungsweise die ISA-Talkens gewartet und das heißt nichts anderes in meiner Lesart.
Also nicht der Bundestag, sondern das Bundes äh Arbeitsministerium ist an der Stelle, äh da der der äh Nutznießer dieser Dienstleistung, aber das macht es ja jetzt auch nicht äh schlimmer. Ähm,
Also nicht besser, Entschuldigung. Ja.
Das heißt, du hast,
deine deine ganze Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung ist im im Arsch, weil du sie denen, weil du sie von Amis hast, machen lassen. Das heißt, die haben den zweiten Faktor. Fertig. Also, das ist schon, das ist schon,
Das ist schon äh witzig,
schon witzig, ja. Aber vielleicht verstehe ich's auch falsch. Also der Vertrag des Bundesarbeits äh Ministeriums mit soll noch Ende November zweitausendvierzehn äh auslaufen.
Er läuft erstmal bis Ende November zwanzig vierzehn, aber dann verlängert wird, das steht jetzt noch auf dem anderen Blatt.
Ja, also der Bundestag, ja, ich denke nicht, dass sie noch weiter mit zusammenarbeiten, wobei jetzt da auch die Frage ist, will man da jetzt wirklich,
Everison, weil ähm RSA der Hersteller dieses ja auch dafür bekannt ist, mit der NSA zusammenzuarbeiten. Insofern,
Es ist alles so kaputt. Also Security ist gerade ähm äh ist gerade eigentlich nichts mehr eine Überraschung.
Schon länger nicht mehr. Kommen wir zu unserem allerletzten Punkt hier. Es wird mal wieder geklagt.
Es wird geklagt.
Nicht nur von uns.
Der ähm der CCC klagt. Ähm,
und zwar zusammen mit Privacy International und äh ich glaube insgesamt sieben internationalen Internet äh.
Anbietern, also Serviceprovider und äh Diensteanbietern
Rise Up Net, äh Green also Rise Up äh aus den USA, Greennet aus Großbritannien, Greenhoest aus den Niederlanden, Mango aus dem,
Gin Bonet aus Korea und äh may first People Link aus den USA und zwar beim,
Investor-Tutorial,
Das ist eine ein juristisches Organ, der ähm britischen Regierung und so eine Art Kontrollkommission, die eben auch äh Beschwerden über unrechtmäßige Überwachung,
entgegennimmt und bearbeitet. Und da wurde also jetzt eine Beschwerde eingelegt in der eben gesagt wird, das sind nicht nur unrechtmäßige Angriffe, die der GCHQ,
gegen Server und Administratoren vornimmt, sondern eben auch,
also ist allgemein destruktives Verhalten für die äh für die Demokratie und auch für äh auf äh Vertrauen und die Sicherheit, die jetzt irgendwie dem Internet äh als Kommunikationsmedium entgegengebracht werden.
Und äh da sollen also die Angriffe auf Kommunikationsdienste und auf Administratoren selbiger äh unterlassen werden. Ja, ich,
ne, das ist ähm inzwischen die dritte juristische,
Anstrengung, die der CCC in der Angelegenheit unternimmt. Gleichzeitig haben wir ja ein Verfahren gegen den äh GCHQ vor dem Europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte laufen,
äh das ja vor einigen Monaten dann auf den Fast-Track gekommen ist und seitdem irgendwie geprüft wird.
Und ähm die dritte war die, sorry.
Noch anhängig. Der Innenminister ist doch auch noch anhängig gewesen, oder?
Ja die die Strafantrag gegen Bundesregierung, Geheimdienste und so weiter.
Beim äh Generalbundesanwalt letztendlich. Ähm also der,
CCC immer fleißig da auch die juristischen Möglichkeiten auszureizen, wobei das, wie gesagt, in keinem dieser Fälle,
nur der CC, sondern,
jeweils die EuGH-Klage auch mit Partnern und die äh die der Strafantrag gegen Bundesregierung und so ähm unter anderem mit der internationalen Liga für Menschenrechte und Digitalcourage zusammen.
Dieses äh sieben Service Provider, äh ich kenne jetzt nur einige der Namen, aber das sind schon auch so ein bisschen die etwas äh aufgeschlosseneren Provider.
Sind ja sehr sehr kleine Kollektive eher
die äh auch spezifisch für Aktivisten äh Dienste bereitstellen. Äh Greenhost aus den Niederlanden kenne ich äh ganz gut.
Und die anderen äh nur vom Namen her. Aber Greenhost ist auch immer mit dabei, wenn's irgendwie so um coole Sachen geht.
Zieht immer mit, die Gang.
Und äh eine weitere Klage hat jetzt äh die IFF angestrengt. Ähm und zwar geht es um ihre Anfrage zum,
Umgang mit Zero Days.
Also die haben gesagt, wir wollen gerne wissen, wie äh die NSA mit mit dem Wissen über Zero Days umgeht. Anlass war da diese ganze Sache, um den,
wo gesagt wurde ja,
schon denkbar, dass die NSA wissen über äh aber ähm,
Da würden wir natürlich jederzeit Bescheid sagen, es sei denn, diese eignet sich
zum Kampf gegen den Terror, was man so ungefähr bei jeder einzelnen Security irgendwie argumentieren kann, zumindest wenn man so verquer argumentiert, äh wie es eben die,
NSA in in dieser gesamten Angelegenheit tut. Und da hat dann die IFF gesagt, na dann wollen wir doch mal ein bisschen mehr wissen über euren Umgang.
Und haben dann da eine einen Freedom of Information gestellt. Der wurde ihnen dann irgendwie nicht,
dem wurde irgendwie nicht entsprochen und deswegen äh haben sie jetzt also eine Beschwerde.
Angestrengt, weil eben ihrem da nicht entsprochen wurde.
Ja und sagen, das ist also eine Verletzung des Freedom of Information Act. Da werden wir sehen, wie weit das,
geht. Ähm ich denke, also ich kann mir nur vorstellen, dass das eine äh eine gekonnte Kollage ist, um dann eben sich die Ablehnung ähm.
Einzufangen und dann eben zu zeigen, okay hier da ist keine Transparenz, wo Transparent sein soll. Oder sie haben jetzt irgendwelche, irgendwelches Wissen oder irgendwelche Hoffnungen bezüglich des,
vor dem, dass dann irgendwann nochmal landet, dass sie da irgendwie Grund zu der Annahme haben, dass da dass sie da nochmal ähm.
Ein ein ein Urteil in ihrem Sinne einfahren können, aber das halte ich jetzt erstmal für eher unwahrscheinlich.
Ja, aber ist auch natürlich auf jeden Fall schon mal äh gut, sowas überhaupt zu machen. Einfach um auch eine eine Öffentlichkeit damit zu erzeugen, auch wenn das nicht die einzige Motivation sein sollte. Äh und am Ende,
zumindest auch äh schauen, wo hat vielleicht auch etwas äh
Also wo hat etwas überhaupt nicht funktioniert, wo hat etwas vielleicht besser funktioniert, als man dachte, man gewinnt dabei ja auch immer wieder Erfahrungen, die man dann später vielleicht, wenn's die Konstellation nicht ganz so kritisch ist, äh,
besser ausspielen kann.
Eben und ich denke, es ist ja, glaube ich, allgemeiner Konsens unter äh auf jeden Fall den
Aktivisten des CCC als auch äh allen anderen Aktivisten, mit denen ich so jetzt gesprochen habe, dass man äh gegen diese ganze NSA-Nummer sich mit allen zur Verfügung stehenden Mitteln.
Wehren muss und da gehören natürlich auch die juristischen zu.
Ähm ebenso wie äh die technischen Verteidigung. Und ähm ja, ich bin da mit der.
Gut, ich kann da jetzt nicht, ich kann da jetzt nicht un äh unbefangen über die Arbeit des CCC äh urteilen, aber ich finde eigentlich kann sehr zufrieden.
Damit wie der Club da gerade.
Auch interessante Tribunale, äh anruft, von denen ich bis vor ein paar Tagen überhaupt nicht wusste.
Gut, ich denke jetzt äh kommen wir hier mal zum Ende. Die äh mal wieder als kurze Sendung angedachte Sendung ist gar nicht kurz geworden, wie das so ist bei uns. Ja.
Ja, ich hoffe, sie war trotzdem unterhaltsam. Äh informativ, sorry.
So früh am Morgen haben wir noch irgendwas? Haben wir noch irgendwelche Ausblicke zu liefern? Mir fällt gerade nix ein.
Mir ist spontan auch nicht.
Ja, sind jetzt einfach nicht mehr spontan. Also bleibt uns nichts anderes übrig, als äh euch eine spannende Woche zu wünschen und,
mal wieder rein, hier wenn's weiter geht mit dem Logbuch. Wir sagen tschüss.
Tschau, tschau.
Bis bald.